of course it's important to remember how
this started we lost a young man Michael
Brown in heartbreaking and tragic
circumstances he was 18 years old his
family will never hold Michael in their
arms again and when something like this
happens the local authorities including
the police have a responsibility to be
open and transparent about how they are
investigating that death and how they
are protecting the people in their
communities there is never an excuse for
violence against police for for those
who would use this tragedy as a cover
for vandalism or looting there's also no
excuse for police to use excessive force
against peaceful protests or to throw
protesters in jail for lawfully
exercising their First Amendment rights
and here in the United States of America
police should not be bullying or
arresting journalists who are just
trying to do their jobs and report to
the American people on what they see on
the ground put simply we all need to
hold ourselves to a high standard
particularly those of us in positions of
authority